hello and welcome to this video coverage
for round two of the candidates
tournament yeah let's get right into the
action we had one winner in round one
with Charlotte what about round two yeah
let's step start with the game Spitler
tu parles wheeler started the event with
a draw and two part of lost that game
against art from very nice position
where you had a big shot on f2 at one
moment yeah what happened today and so
we've got the bill in defense um and 2
pi love goes for that again after you
lost 22 and yesterday maybe a slight
surprise that is not going for something
a little bit more enterprising yeah I
don't know swinger goes for castles 94
and rookie one this is a line that
always surprises me but is some if
someone plays it at least there someone
plays it who has some ambition to win
because I think this is just so dead
boring equal that I really don't see the
point and get in this game we see what
I'm talking about so they play this and
all this is well known here white also
has deform which is also entirely equal
93 was played here and now we see two
part of employing the well-known
equalizing method against this 9895 now
Bishop to b6 and all the white pieces
are pushed back Bishop back here and now
see form a 97 d 485 yeah it's super
logical and this has been played already
in games before yes villano takes on d5
and now we see a no team the move Knight
takes d5 was played by a corona with
black against Carlton in London
last year after this and Bishop f4 White
had a slight pool ultimately Kara wanna
do this quite comfortably but here we
see that white has a little bit more
development and even though the position
is very very yeah Indy make this is the
word it's it's a slide pool for wide at
least yeah but now I'm kepala actually
has an improvement he plays business
move checking the rook so Bishop detours
to be played and Swilley I was taking a
bit of time there takes takes takes here
or maybe that was a wrong relay error
okay so we have all these trades and I
really don't see the point in this in
this opening for white because I mean
who are you going to beat here someone
who's kind of falling debt over the
board or something it just is just
totally boring at equal and after a
couple of moves it traded a little bit
more and agree to a draw so kind of a
non game and I really don't understand
what why players do here I mean okay I
understand if you just want to draw
that's so cool but you also always get
this kind of position and I mean that
this cannot be the point of playing a
playing this this opening to get this
pollution after move 14 yeah sorry if
I'm renting you anything and they really
don't mean any anything yeah no I don't
want to bash players or anything it's
just I think it's it's terribly I'm an
exciting to play in such a way and if
that's really everything that white has
against the building defense they should
really start with other moves like on
move one or move three or something like
that anyway it's of course if you are
okay with a draw why not so um next game
aronian are not I promise that was a
little bit more interesting um
we have Queens gambit declined and
unlock goes for Knight B to D seven this
is an interesting line that has caught
some mentum in recent years the main
idea of Ovid is that after Bishop to e7
which is the most frequent move Bishop
f4 is a big theoretical discussion we've
seen this line only yesterday in geary
aronia and with night bt7 on black is
basically equipping himself to play
differently against Bishop f4 after
Bishop f4 which Aronian was playing now
I like to conceive for and of course why
can go Bishop to g5 the traditional way
of playing the Queens gambit declined
but here black has a couple of
interesting options he can go and Bishop
e7 of course for the very classical
Queens gambit declined or you can still
play Bishop to be form form a form of
the Rogozin variation so this was played
and Anna took yeah interesting line III
was played and now and yeah we she is
coming with the latest latest trend down
the move be fire this actually was
played against me in a blitz game just a
couple of days ago and that was kind of
interesting I kind of saw i know that
this move existed but i had no idea not
sure that that video is already released
but only recently and someone played
this against me um yeah takes on db5
this is pretty much clearer if why does
not take you will probably just be a
pawn down so this was okay check and now
92 by aronia yeah the move Knight c3 is
more common here
after which black usually goes for 95
and we see the idea of all this black
gets quick activity and with this check
coming with the tempo and he uses the
fact that this pressure on c3 and
simultaneously on f4 is slightly awkward
for white and the resulting positions
are really quite similar to what we have
in the game maybe a group see one night
7b six this is some the way it usually
plays out and that move 92 was only
recently employed by Boris Gelfand in
the aeroflot I open against post-grad
chef so it's a recent recently
introduced idea in fact we follow that
gelfand game for quite a while um but
for both sides the moves are very
logical 95 and what um taxes specific
way 976 protecting see form and Quincy
to attacking this even more yeah castles
now um if white now takes on c form the
night takes Queen takes and Bishop a6 is
a big issue yeah this is a very awkward
pin and yeah White has a hard time here
and will actually already lose em if he
implies some let's say equals a 4 and to
lend some support there is c6 needed
after Queen takes c6 check Jack Queen a
5 and a black is already winning yeah
something like this is a dandy attack so
why cannot take them it has to be a
little bit more modest here with Bishop
e2 yeah Bishop a six-night comes back NC
5 we see black really getting some
activity going why took on c5 yeah and
here in this position grad chef the
black player played against galfond
Bishop takes 25
after Knight takes he went knight takes
Bishop c4 Bishop c4 94 rook c8 yeah and
black had some compensation for the pony
had some technical ideas him um I want
however plays differently he takes on c3
pawn takes on Ben Bishop c5 yeah so and
now a novelty in this currently
fashionable line yeah what about this
position how to assess that black
actually has a little bit more space in
this position he has established that
pawn on c4 which is currently yeah a
little bit limiting white and his
freedom of movement on the other hand
that point also is a liability can be
attacked um what's pieces are also quite
decent here the bishop Iran g3 the
bishop here can be activated while
black's pieces on a six in particular
and b 6 p-6 hmm but a six in particular
look rather passive it's probably around
equal castles rook c8 lending some more
supporters see porn and now queen g5
Australia the Queen had to leave them
the D file and now come into g6 yeah
it's all very logical i guess if white
now takes and what's possible then
position is even more simplified I guess
white was varied let it move like 95
soon would be a little bit awkward for
that see porn now that cannot be easily
defended here by a minor piece and you
really don't like to play rook a c1 and
reply to that so maybe he didn't want to
move the Queen away from that protection
of the see Paul I know it looks a bit
weird yeah he put it and he only one but
it's not a totally totally awful idea
the queen is yeah out of
yeah reach form for blacks before
black's pieces and why it has some ideas
he anyway like 95 and Bishop h4 in case
of root da da Queen f6 yeah I still
think it's it's roughly equal we had
Bishop a for coming 95 and clean up and
now rook to d2 yeah and now um there's a
concrete sequence that that happens roop
t8 and here aronian basically decided if
you if you want the code like that to
end the game um and I think
understandably so if you try something
here with white you maybe can come into
some kind of trouble here because of
your your lack of space a little bit so
when I talk about this is he took them
Queen takes and just night x they're
taking that pawn and this is not winning
a pawn because and black has this shot
but this is what I mean with ending the
game we now have a um yeah this all
trades down now to nothing if white now
he took on in three if he tries to be
fancy with Bishop a six and black indigo
Bishop t2 Queen can move here for
example and a black it goes back here
and this again nothing happening it's
equal material this happened Andrew P 1
yeah if white takes on a seven here this
is also not not doing that much yeah
he's his 10 corner but there's
absolutely nothing to hope for those two
pawns are weak and black gets easy play
for example something like age six is a
good movie are securing against back
rank mates and then shooting for 25 and
Bishop c6 no problem at all this is a
bit more interesting threatening rupee
eight rook c8 and h3 again white could
have taken but after Bishop c2 he
doesn't have a decent yeah white cannot
move the rook up
because it's made and something like
that it's just absolutely nothing yeah
in the game h3 was played a six and ce4
giving away that pawn but it ends the
game as I said now we have got the trade
trade of everything that same and she
have to create they agreed to a draw now
you can ask why did they agree to draw
isn't black upon up yes he is but they
didn't even feel like it makes any sense
to continue the game in the first place
yeah it's really a very Jewish position
um the Queen's now have to be traded and
I just want to quickly show why this is
so dry we've got opposite colored
bishops here and the typical way of
drawing this with a porn down is to hold
one side of the board one wing here he
had the Queen side with the bishop and
the other side is to be held with a king
so what wide will be doing him he will
just play let's say black players let's
say of sexy white gives him and black
girls here and white plains III yeah he
would always keep this covered with the
bishop at least in case of the black
king attacking this pawn then you will
always have the bishop to cover it and
what wide will do is he will just put
put something like this up here and just
from here on just stay and do nothing
yeah black what ultimately advances
pawns there will be some porn trades on
the King side and at the end there will
just be one porn left that the White
King will block it is a fairly
straightforward business um and it
doesn't really yeah makes so much sense
on that level to play that out so they
just agree to draw saving some energy
and time him it's not a bad thing in a
40 round tournament okay so that was a
draw and
next game spin between kawana and geary
yeah you're already suspected it is the
Bullen and this time kawana goes 483
this is arguably maybe the most
interesting try nowadays we've seen the
five rupee one line in Silla to pile of
which is yeah a total non try in my book
and the endgame we have not seen yet the
Queen descend the end game with that you
usually call the Berlin Wall ending and
this is a digital three line yet which
is probably the most interesting okay
Bishop c5 see three castles castles we
see the same line as in the first round
between to Parliament online or a lot
Apollo is the right way to put it and
yeah very very similar position um d5
now however was played that's a
different approach to the compared to
the the online game 5 29 37 yeah this
position already a has been has been
tested and it is with kawana on the
black side actually that this position
was played before in a game to pile of
kawana said Lewis 2015 and two part of
played the move from a form and after a
five like a four a five he went back to
d1 yeah that doesn't look too inspiring
and to move the Queen back but if we
look at the game yeah I think I wanna
put the Queen back immediately I think
the idea problem is that it is a bit
difficult who wide to get his his
position coordinated with the Queen
being on v3 you can actually question
what was the Queen going to
III in the first place but I think the
point is that you want to maybe em gap
provoke some weaknesses on the queenside
with this move or some kind of
commitment in the center it's very
difficult anyway for white as the
default point is hanging in some way I
have to I mean if you are still in the
pin you have to look a lookout for that
for that pawn in some situations yeah
okay so we had Queen d1 and now I'm give
you place at an interesting fashion he
directly attacked schweitzer at white
center but with f6 it's an interesting
move definitely um and after that we
really get some get some sharp lame yeah
he's 6 quite clearly everything else
everything else is completely harmless
yeah so night back to be 8 and 9 p-3 I
guess quite logical why it has to put
that bishop on c1 to some use and queen
to d6 for exactly that reason Bishop f4
what's the idea for exactly that reason
26 display to prevent bishop coming to
that natural square yeah position now
gets really sharp G for getting rid of
that pin and push your pointy end and
lie to an eye to h4 this has two ideas
maybe three the first and most direct
idea is to being able to play Knight f5
at a at a good moment we see that later
in the game second idea might be to free
their three square so that Queen f3
Bishop f4 becomes an option this
disinfect looks rather relevant and an
additional idea could be to play like
fy5 on a very good day but this is not a
day
that yeah not this day fy5 is very
unrealistic but would be cool to get in
if you can manage to yes cement this
pawn on 96 okay um night bc six was
played yeah that night couldn't stay
there forever and is the tech as the
default point as well yeah koalas
approach now is very very
straightforward he plays Bishop c6
interesting move if 96 now then night f5
becomes an interesting move black
probably has to take and white has
established this strong pawn it is not
clear that this is yeah like Fantastic
Four right but it looks like some way
forward Queen takes was played yeah and
now the next move I found a little bit
surprising but it does have a point of
course the move on Bishop to d2 why it's
not intending who are here but rather to
be form and use this bishop to harass
blacks blockading night yeah very direct
planar bokhiria place plez bishops you
too and now takes on b3 what's the point
yeah just snatch the pawn this is
dangerous however for black um there
were alternatives a black for example I
could have played Quincy to an
interesting move and try to get this
pawn and at the same time also looking
at this so if Bishop before oops sorry
we should be Freud's played and black
probably can take and play rupee eight
without being in any big danger yeah
something like that
looks dangerous at first but black will
play g6 and kick this night out and
ultimately the a64 now looks weak
interesting alternative that move is
risky and maybe could have yeah and led
to led to trouble forgiving this should
be for Bishop c5 yeah I know it was
difficult yeah if you go here then white
is just taking and playing that fork
they are so Bishop c5 yeah and now rook
see one forcing b6 not very
attractive-looking this move but had to
be played take stakes and now rook a six
by caruana that's a that's a good move
there also was repair five and you could
argue maybe this was even stronger it's
it's it's a tough case of comparing too
complicated lines by its idea is simply
to take and take take both points as
possible black mmm probably should play
something like c4 giving the pawn in
that way and something like this and
this is given as the top line by the
computers however why definitely um it's
somewhat better here you can argue what
the best movement says before this
Knight f3 before it's interesting again
intending to get maybe use the rukon c5
here white is definitely better we have
something like this Knight f3 and black
get some blankets in some trouble
however rook a6 as played by kawana it's
not bad either Queen back and Roxy 5
yeah rook e8 now is played and the next
move probably um is giving away White's
advice
which um he played the move Queen to be
five and yeah this is ultimately doesn't
lead to much there was night f5 and this
is something where black has to be very
very precise to not get into big trouble
and then couldn't really find a complete
equality if black for example takes on
b3 here then rook a3 is a move Queen to
be seven and twin sent to yeah why does
directing all is heavy pieces against
the Queen side and black has a hard time
here something like this this this and
this is already pretty much lost so
black has to be very precise and rook c8
is an alternative not grabbing the pawn
there in the first place but after
something like rock d3 intending to take
here and here this is also better for
wider takes takes c6 and now this to put
more pressure on the pawn so it looks
like instead of Queen B 5 the move
Knight f5 or stronger um the time relay
is not precise but the way it looks at
least it seems that Kara wanna had some
time issues this is very very post very
much possible yeah he played Queen to be
five as mentioned and this is um yeah
giving black a much easier life takes
takes d4 there's some come to play yeah
here again white could have preserved
you know it's got more time on the clock
again and maybe the clock times here you
can simply a yeah not take serious I
mean it was tricky because of that legal
mumbo jumbo by that we had a gone
company I think as he couldn't relate
the Musa
ya could relate the moose by by
conventional means that had to do
something else is probably screwed up
the times um anyway deform and now a
MOOC c5 was still a try for 4h Jenna
likes is 69 f5 and here white is still
retaining a slight edge but he will
probably have to at the end be content
with the draw this line is quite quite
quite nice and the funny point is that
here black should play king to have
eight and not d3 looks totally known
what white has this funky idea group t5
it's a very nice idea that you can
easily overlook yeah quite nice and yeah
here Black is in some trouble he has to
play this because the capture is leading
to made and a couple of moose funny
checkmate has to do this then whoop t 7t
to hoop cd6 the funny way right this is
this and here why does of course better
yeah but okay black can improve this by
playing king of eight and sorry here
king of eight and this he will very
likely draw the most probable
continuation or something like that king
of one like a group d 8 35 takes takes
takes takes yeah and why it has this
extra porn and form of a double porn but
white is a little bit a little bit
better because he's a little bit quicker
with a king and yeah it's a porn after
all it's not like it was going to be I
know the big passer that will be
promoted but at least that is an extra
porn that black has to take in many many
lines and white at least can try out so
as a somewhat more active rook um in the
game and the immediate night f5 has
played and now after
rookie a Droog at seven and Brooke f5
and sorry night f5 that off is it out to
draw in fact gear he could have played
g6 yeah which is already something where
why it has to be able to careful he will
be drawing at the end but check this
this we see that this is an issue and
this porn is more of a weakness than a
particular strength white will
ultimately draw I guess with moves like
I know this may be um Teague's and his
d3 um Luke c5 Rupert e7 rookie one was a
line that i was looking at and it's
equal material the d porn is not that
strong probably a draw in the game this
was played t3 and now g6 again this
trades down to and pretty much nothing
yeah here they here they agree to draw
possible continuation is this is this
this and it's eco material and no passes
nothing so draw him um slight
disappointment maybe for caruana he
hadn't had chances definitely if he is
more precise with that night f5 moves
instead of Queen to be five okay so
three drawers and we are going to look
at kayaking like a [ __ ] next um okay so
we've got a defaulting again yeah
karaoke not playing as usual or more
frequently seen efore service um and is
playing the second white camera also
nice okay so we have this and now I'm
like a more place and move b6 and it is
the Queen's indian defence and opening
that in recent years
wasn't so popular there is no particular
reason for that the opening is
completely sound and and reliable one
reason maybe for the UM Jeff one for the
less frequent use of it is that why it
has so many options against that is not
so easy for the black player to be
prepared against all of them yeah wife
can play a 3g 393 III here or and ends
up blind sub variations it's not so easy
for black to you have to be confident in
all of those I think it's I think it's
on the top level and sometimes easier
for those people to prepare for Queens
gambit swear the place often a little
bit more more force than more direct you
can use the computer better okay um
Nakamura is not a frequent practitioner
of that opening and it's quite funny
that he plays against kayaking was
widely regarded as the biggest Queens
Indian expert in the world so it's quite
funny that they have it with this color
with this carlos the other if you would
determine its its nakamura kayak and
that would be much more likely okay g3
by kayak in the camera goes Bishop a
six-step modern main line of the opening
provoking the move b3 and now just
before check this is one reason why um
black is provoking the move there be
three on that check now white doesn't
have an ideal reply he would like to
play Bishop b2 and night BTW to as as
ideal setup um so night ability to write
that looks like looks looks normal the
problem however is that here there is
even this funky move down and after
rugby one
black goes Bishop d7 and this is very
awkward this is hanging yeah and it's
not easy for y2 to find a decent movie
if you go III hmm that starts to be very
embarrassing yeah so funny stuff White
has to play Bishop b2 and now black goes
back to e7 so he spends two moves here
to provoke that bishop here so right now
is pretty far away from having a bishop
here and then hi Tandy too so black is
using a little bit of time to misplace
White's pieces Bishop g2 and now the
move d5 this is a surprising choice by
Nakamura here by yeah by a mile the main
move is c6 black tries to play d5 the
same as in the game but in the game
receive after this white eggs and now
black is taking with the EEP on the move
c6 is preparing d5 and black tries to be
ready to capture back with the Seaport
so let's just assume let's say white
wood castle maybe bishops III is more
testing well let's say castles d5 and
now this doesn't make much sense but
just to show the idea now black can
easily recapture with the sea pawn &
okay here why does absolutely nothing
even 96 is possible you so often more
often than not black cow c6 to prepare
that move but nakamura plays it
immediately d5 and now of the sea takes
it takes we get a pawn structure that is
usually seen as somewhat less sound or
less reliable then that structure which
is six the reason is if we can put a
couple of more moves on the
like this the reason is that with this
kind of queenside configuration um at
one point it's very likely that black
will play the move c7 to see 5.2 c5 as
the point on c7 will be somewhat weak in
the long run very likely he will play c5
and then there are only two scenarios
wide we'll take on c5 and let's
unpainted of it why it will take on c5
and we have one of two scenarios black
will take with a piece which gives black
and isolated queen pawn not so ideal
yeah it doesn't look like he has tons of
activity or he has to take with the beep
on this and then we get the so-called
hanging pawns that pawn due on c5 and d5
that also is quite often a bit weak
especially against a white v Aikido so
this is a somewhat surprising choice by
the cameras there is relatively little
upside to Black's setup it's not
terribly bad it's just a slightly risky
strategically and okay Quincy to rupee 8
and look to d1 yeah anticipating that at
some point c5 and details will be played
then the ruckus exactly right here night
f8 regroup in that night to e 6 this is
usually a quite good square for the
night in those structures because went
from a six year the night looks at those
two crucial squares 95 wide uses this
opportunity that this squares easily
available Bishop d7 bag a c6 was too
weak Bishop see 196 and Bishop b2 yeah
bishop see one then pretty long and
slowish maneuver but it's about quality
sometimes
not about doing something in a
particular um yeah not rushing things
but quality is sometimes more important
the bishop just belongs on that diagonal
on d to it just doesn't make any sense
so a good maneuver by kayak and he has
the slightly more comfortable position
here for the reasons that I mentioned
it's difficult for black to ya not move
the Sheep or never and here ultimately
nakamura decided to ya to move it may
plate plate c5 this is some I think I'm
the best decision in the long run you
cannot sit there passively all the time
and after takes Knight takes he gets to
that isolated greenhorn position um this
position here if you look at this 93 is
quite logical and 924 this position type
is seen quite frequently in the Queen's
Indian and related openings yeah this
disposition also could have arisen from
from some kind of Catalan for example
but usually from the Queen's in Ian and
those iqp positions are a little bit
different then um I QP positions that
arise let's say when White has got the
IQ pee outside of the the panel of
attack of the caro-kann or outside or
coming from some kind of Queens gambit
accepted where the site with the IQ p
sometimes really can play for direct
attack based on its active pieces black
here has reasonably active pieces but
this for example doesn't really look so
so great yeah for some kind of attack
why it's a king side and whole setup is
also so solid that black cannot really
dream of any King side action but black
is reasonably active still not only for
is good Roxy a Droog on the eighth there
on how
open files in most cases Black is able
to compensate this slide weakness cm on
d5 by this active piece play so Nakamura
is slightly worse iam but it's usually
something that blacks should be able to
manage and I think he plays it quite
quite ok right queen b 1 27 or
everything's yeah get towards active
piece play take stakes and b5 yeah
you're not so happy about a move like
that because you're putting another pony
on a light squared and it's not doesn't
look so great here for this bishop but
it's also ultimately not the end of the
world before now by kayak in a good move
certainly are fixing this square that
may be white can put something on c5
which Nakamura immediately prevents by
going 97 a three now he regroups that to
use excel so lots of funny night
maneuvers yeah Queen to a to Bishop see
Sapna that Bishop is coming over there
and now the move age falls played by
kayak in a slightly mysterious move via
at all seem to be set on on Queen side
play and then all of a sudden the move h
form the only point probably being too
control g5 which didn't seem so relevant
okay and this is the key moment of this
game and maybe of the round because it
is the starting point of the only
decides the result of the whole the
whole round and what Nakamura now
probably should do and it doesn't look
very inspiring but probably has to to
take orders him and maybe player some g6
Queen f6 of that and yeah try to hold
this position it's not much fun this is
not a great bishop
but still Black is very solid and has
certainly has drawing chance it's not
like he's losing him but it is probably
what he has to do I mean this is not the
not a great position but it somehow the
position that Nakamura went for with
this whole opening selection so he has
to play that kind of not so great
position and defend instead he now um
just committed yeah always have to be M
always very reluctant to say us say that
word is really a blunder yeah nowadays
when everybody can can look at the
computer evils here every move that kind
of gift so we have a pawn as a blunder
um and this is really not the case I
mean human beings bound to make mistakes
so it's not like blunder or whatever
it's all it's just a difficult game and
sometimes you cannot find the right
moves all the time but in some cases it
really is a big blonde and this is what
nakamura place now he takes on g3 and
this sacrifice simply does not work at
all he has overlooked um a little detail
cakes a 94 that was his idea and Bishop
takes Bishop takes pawn takes jack and
the check and yeah one thing is that
this is not possible like winds iam what
if the King moves and black can grab the
night but there is Queen f2 and now in
order to maintain materially quality at
first you have to take the night and now
Luke c7 and this is what he must have
overlooked this Hanks and white is
threatening on f7 so it's just a piece
nakamura basically blunder to peace with
night x-23 as he didn't um yeah he
caught it back but he overlooked that
rook c7
at the end of the line yeah he continued
for a couple of moves probably being
rather frustrated f5 and that's it
Bishop gets taken yeah the following
chat part of the game is not exactly
difficult this was something that
kayaking yet to see before-and-after
rookie to there's the move Bishop f1 and
that's the end of game yeah he and
nakamura resigned as after Luke f2 and
Bishop takes here why just retreats the
bishop and it's looking at that porn so
black is not able to snatch pawns here
as this is going to be um yeah even
worse than just being a piece down this
is probably some kind of checkmating net
already so a very disappointing result
here for the my american number one you
see the number one I'm sorry if I'm
screwing this up maybe Caruana has a
higher rating anyway Nakamura some
results certainly a disappointment for
for his fans and slightly strange game I
was surprised by the choice of opening
and position type and then instead of
defending this passively yeah but it was
necessary he yeah committed that mistake
with Knight takes two three so I'm after
two rounds we have vishy anand and saggy
kayak in leading the event with the plus
one score both have won a game with
white and yeah it's quite funny this
those two were also the first first and
second-place finishes of the candidates
tournament two years ago but that was
after 14 rounds not after 20 two rounds
so many more rounds to come and even for
ya for Nakamura who's now certainly am
they're not very pleased with himself
being on minus one in for him they are
still um yeah everything to play for it
still everything's possible ok I hope
you enjoyed the coverage of
onto thanks for watching